are we ready bring that michael are you
ready yes are you guys ready yeah yeah
that's your mind are you [ __ ] ready
i'm [ __ ] ready if it's easier are you
[ __ ] ready chin hold on i don't know
you can come back
couple things before we start i got so
much to talk you look like you have aids
between us
i know but but listen listen i look like
i have rickets when you don't get enough
calcium in the womb
you think very good when you're growing
up what is that rickets is a calcium
deficiency it's when you don't have
enough nutrition
are you telling me the truth yes and
that's good now
very let me get seven man muscle let's
go ahead and get our that what right 500
pounds of man
yeah let's go ahead and get her look at
that let me get i got
this let me just a lot of man let's go
ahead and get our tickets
for lol comedy this weekend
daddy needs to push tickets yeah
oklahoma city but i guess go to
brickstown next week [ __ ] off now
that's what i have to say now that's the
first thing now there's a couple things
i'll sit next to mark
daddy sit next to mark i do i set you up
at uh hotel emma though
my guy reached out to you i'm excited
i'm excited yes thank you for that
um but it doesn't matter none of that
matters because i'm never going to be
happy why am i
you'll be happy at ho hotel hotel emma
but why would i be happy when i could
have looked like that
you can't though i can't because when
god was giving out genetics he went ah
counts back of the line back of the line
mark up front the mold is marked right
the m that would be the masculine
when when he made the mold and then he
poured a little batter
he didn't pour enough batter you know
when you're making waffles into the
waffle thing
you got just a little they ran out of
batter with make some [ __ ] yeah
i'm a flap cake you're a flap cake we
got a fork no one in your family looks
like that
absolutely not sorry because you're
sicilian right my
grandpa's also sicilian yeah and what
else what else irish
okay i'm getting lost in your blue eyes
right now i know right and he's awesome
he was staring he's an italian irish
touch of unicorn
oh touch a unicorn you know what's you
know what he's not a meathead he's funny
no no no that's
super funny just thought i looked in his
eyes and i just thought i was in
on a raft in the middle of the aegean
sea okay and you don't know where the
gnc is not it's [ __ ] it's blue bro oh
can i see a bridge
without the aceh
are you sure you don't want 550 because
you know lifting
all out he's a trainer too so he said he
sent me he sent me the video
right now there you go that's blue and
mark's eyes that's sparkly i thought i
was on a raft in the middle of that
ocean
wow beautiful it's a beautiful ocean
have you been to the eggs yes i have
i've sailed
don't lie to me now i'm not because you
lie a lot of people spend enough time in
beirut and
greece in the mediterranean in that area
so you you you find yourself in the
aegean his dad was the first and if you
want to know what it's like
look at his eyes okay now look at his
eyes
now now um i saw him do the deadlift and
here's what's scared
no hold on before before you so since
we've been lifting with mark
wednesday's is it's deadlift wednesday
it's a thick boy summer and summer was
monday
okay so i thought you know what what a
way to kick off the summer by doing a
personal best 600 because you never felt
stronger
nobody knows it was coming nobody i mean
no i didn't i
woke up i woke up groggy he'll get
competitive
no it wasn't even competitive but you're
a natural competitor yeah
right you want even just with yourself
if you put an idea in your head sure
like cause i
actually said 600 as a joke i'm like
you're going for 600 a day you're like
yeah let's load it up you want to do so
you can play through 600.
before that don't want to be responsible
for advocating because
then i got to go for 600 marcos let's
not do that and i went
shut up mark and then we loaded the
weight on and now
my back's a little tweaked now now papa
couldn't do
601 or 602 that took every ounce of
power that had my body
and i know that because my eyes were
going like he's got the strength to pull
600
but not with perfect technique so there
was a little bend in the back wasn't
there
and when i saw that little bend yeah
when i saw that wink
i went
your stone finger if you want to give me
notes on your hand
when it comes to lifting you shut
[ __ ] yourself properly you shut your
dirty hard mouth i'll show you
watch out move out of the way this is i
want to show you you got proper
technique
all right yeah but you lift 100 pounds
so we don't care i wanted this from
i wanted this one yep yes flat back
okay i want this here we are now i did
that another six sets papa
i might be i'm not even looking this way
right now i'm here
you're 60. yep you're 60. yep now your
grip's
off that's whatever your grip is off
might be a little off
yeah now what i saw here was this i saw
this and then round and then we did a
little rounding now you'll see
power lifters do that i just get nervous
that right there i saw that his butt
winked in
and now we got a problem and guess what
he's got a problem with his back
it's just it's just a little strain but
here's the thing though papa did that
exact technique for the first six sets
when we get to 600 you'll learn this
down the road no you won't you know
the thing is when you get really heavy
you do whatever it takes
but you learned a little bit when you
were doing your powerlifting about the
deadlift
listen dude i've i'm i do you know you
guys guys come on i'll give you credit
and you know that's that's that's that
mark and at that gym
when i say this no one gave a [ __ ] no
one even batted an eye to 600. that's a
lot it's a meathead gym they were like
nah whatever
yeah what do you pull mark uh i did 4.95
today and that's about
my limit i'm not that strong yeah
well i'm like i'm okay but i'm going
there's nothing about any lift i do
that's exceptional
i'm pretty strong couldn't be happier
with your legs and your ass
i did 425 squat high bar ass to grass so
maybe if i do low bar
and like you know as like i went below
like competition squat i don't know like
450.
but we gotta we gotta we got a gorilla
here we gotta we gotta brendan is
is abnormally strong weird strong yeah
like he as i was saying earlier
we hadn't been deadlifting like and he
just like we so
when we started lifting he like hadn't
he's like oh i haven't lifted him for
yeah throw 315 in the bar i don't
know so he does certain things you go oh
and wish chappelle too because people
will message me like
what's the secret with these guys i'm
like well you're dealing with two elite
athletes don't expect yourself to have
these same
right just as far as fast twitch muscle
fibers go yes right
when you have i don't know what those
are but yeah oh that's the video cal
that's what i'm saying so but yeah we're
good
brendan's grip for example i train grip
i do every you know pull-ups and rows
and all [ __ ]
i can't double overhand 500 pounds so
even to hold on to the bar i know use
straps for the 600 but that's a little
bit you know
oh here it goes look at bam bam [ __ ]
bam bam now i should be doing it
flat-footed but i thought you know what
it'd look cool in yeezys
then my back went i don't think so bro
you should have done but i'm going to
say not that bad of a hitch
you know all things being considered you
can you can find a lot worse form on the
internet so
brendan wanted the rep i didn't i had my
skepticism because we
the last rep he did was he did 500 for
for four and he was like i had some in
the tank i'm gonna go for 600.
um and i was like i don't want to be
responsible for advocating that i don't
want to be like go try it so i was like
you did say no
i knew he was really strong because i
watched him bam bam some big-time
jiu-jitsu guys who were big dudes
yeah and i watched him i would watch him
kind of he'd get that
next gear and go get somebody off yeah
and one guy was real famous guy and i
went i remember looking at my and the
guy i could see the guy goes uh that's
that's a different gear that i'm not i
ca i don't have technique for that but
yeah but why did i do that to him brian
because he's mean to you
yeah and i beat the [ __ ] out of him that
was true true and then you saw
that someone was mean oh cool dude you
want to be mean to brian all right let's
go
he's like i'm good on it no we're going
what's he really you for yeah he did he
just rides
back yeah so bam bam over here was like
well you can't do that to the old man
but then
then the samoan guy was 300 pounds in a
black belt said shob
and went like that and brennan went well
he goes
watch this and i watched i watched
brendan look
take a samoan guy with 300 pounds and
train and go your strength and kung fu
is no good here
it's no good here because i'm going to
snap you down and i'm gonna i'm gonna
anaconda you with my [ __ ]
600 pound pulling arms and it was very
interesting to watch yeah it's very
interesting
let me see that i haven't seen kyle's
take on it
wait wait let me get the audio
kyle the photographer wizard over there
that bar is [ __ ] bending yeah just
bending so really not that much thoracic
bending
no
get a ton of thoracic bending and and
you can't that's usually like you won't
be able to lock it up because your
back's completely bent over at the top
um now i want this to be clear i want
everyone to know i could only do 300
pounds then i bought that thick boy
t-shirt
i can do it yeah it's it is
that shirt adds 300
yeah it's 300 pounds of your deadlift a
lot of chatter online about people's
lives
is that right around the church i don't
have anything i don't have any thick boy
merch cause you're too skinny
well i may be a stick boy but it doesn't
mean i can't wear a thick boy
summer is almost here kids which means
it's father's day and it's coming up go
to omahasteaks.com type in
fighter in the search bar and order dad
to get
out and grill assortment it includes 20
entrees
he's guaranteed to love the ultra juicy
burgers
plum chicken breasts sides desserts a
four ounce
four 10 ounce butchers cut new york
strips these strips are aged over 30
days so they're extra
tasty and why is that important listen
age
equals tenderness plus get a four free
new york strip burgers with your order
these are ultra lean and pack a bold
intense flavor
oma steaks isn't just steaks y'all it's
the best steak of your life guaranteed
omaha steak sent me a bunch of meat and
i can't stop grilling the new york
strips they're burgers i feed the whole
fam
my dad was grilling some bull crap
burger i said papa
we gotta get you on omaha steaks dude he
said what's that i said just wait to
father's day yo
just wait it's coming man go to
omahastakes.com keyword fighter if you
love your dad
visit omahastakes.com keyword fighter
and order the get out and grill
assortment for your papi
send dad more than just a gift send him
an experience he'll love and can share
with you
and the whole family we all get to eat
the meat in your mouth
and don't forget for limited time get
four free new york strip burgers with
your order
that's omahasteaks.com keyword fighter
listen i'm the president of thick boy
bike club
and i'm president of thick boys out
there and there's nothing makes you feel
fatter than when you down
just a big old bear at a ball game or
maybe at home watching a fight whatever
it is
you feel bloated you feel fully like man
i did all this working out
i've been eating right i just want a
cold one i wish there was something
tastier but also healthy
and then core said that's a great idea
what about
coors pure you fat pizza and they design
coors pure that's right coors pure it's
all organic has zero sugar you enjoy it
without feeling guilty
all right if you ever feel pressure to
keep help with being a healthy
person course pure got you covered man
course pure organic but they're chill
about it
new course pure is refreshingly simple
bare with organic barley organic hops
water 92 calories and zero sugar it's
the perfect bear to celebrate the winds
of life
every freaking day of course pure is the
perfect bear to celebrate the winds of
every life every day i said it twice
so when you want to enjoy a bear without
the guilt reach for coors pure it's
organic
but they're chill about it go to course
pure dot com see where you can find
course pure
celebrate responsibly coors brewing
company albany georgia
father's day is coming up nothing says i
love you like a pack of
course pure now i want this to be
clear i want everyone to know i could
only do 300 pounds then i bought that
thick boy t-shirt
i can do 400 pounds yeah it's it is what
it
does
that shirt adds 300 pounds let them say
it again
t-shirts yeah yeah it's 300 pounds
you're dead
a lot of chatter online about people's
lists is that right
around the church i don't have anything
i don't have any thick boy merch because
you're too skinny
well i may be a stick boy but it doesn't
mean i can't wear a thick boy
overwhelmingly asking me to start the
stick boy merch kind of
all right now let me see this this is
this is the coveted side view this is
this is this
view mark this where you see a little
bend in the back not a lot of bend
you're right you're right mark there's
not a lot of bent but
just didn't know how easy that's just
too much weight bubba you gotta be
careful
602 i couldn't do i got it no i couldn't
do six it's got to be
it's scary 600 is [ __ ] insane what
did i do for
you did 425 today i did looking really
good did 420 dude
chappelle couldn't do [ __ ] when he first
hey you [ __ ] you gotta say it like that
yes
but you get a guy like that what are you
gonna say like this mark am i right well
you get you ain't saying i didn't do
[ __ ] i had a little
it was tough dude your bait were you
your base to where you're at now is
insane you started
yeah hey and then it's like yeah you're
here
i started here yeah now you're doing
four you're pulling four to five
yeah well what the hell like honestly he
could have done it
yeah i could have probably done a few
but i i just really want to focus on the
technique
yeah i don't want to like because i know
these things can like [ __ ] you up if
you're not doing
things correctly you have good beverages
for you know lifting the 425
who has the video kyle no all
of real muscle yeah now i want you to
manipulate my endocrines
okay so i go i have i have six months
okay and i want
10 pounds of real muscle i want legs
that i want my jeans my quads to have
problems
in yeah i want to have a problem now we
can't do that i want to go buy new genes
yeah okay um so i want many i want to
look as close
i'm never going to reach you but at
least i look like brad pitt i want that
i want that form brad pitt and fight
club yeah
but actually i always advocate to people
is is
them i'll start off with the mistakes
that i see people make i want to get big
i'm doing a bro split where i'm hitting
chest on mondays
arms on tuesdays hamstrings on thursdays
it's like hell yeah you're spreading it
out too much
what i would do is if you were trying if
you have six months you want to get as
big as possible
do everything every day but the minimal
like do heavy as [ __ ] shoulder press
heavy bench press heavy like if you
could squat every day or dead lift every
day but just a few intense sets right
like high intensity low volume and
repeat that
it's it's sort of some people there's
body builders out there who do
a full body five days a week wow but for
legs one day all they're doing is
five sets of lunges okay so because when
you do a leg day for two hours
by the time you get to the third
exercise how much fun do you have in the
tank
right so i would rather go in and go i'm
gonna do for example like
there were years where i'd just do two
intense sets of squats anytime i did a
leg day
for for my quads at least you do one set
to failure at 10 and then one set of
failure at 20.
have you ever done a 20 set barbell
squat to failure
it's nightmare absolutely right yeah so
that
you don't need a lot of weight well it
would be as heavy as you can for 20. so
that would be you would figure out that
percentage
right but it isn't you're not it's not a
triple right so
if you do the compound movements because
an overhead press versus a lateral raise
like
you could say i'm going in and doing 10
sets me and chappelle did we we did the
sets
leading up to the max lifts we did like
you know my five places you did 425 and
rented at 600. yeah the 425's right
there by the way just in case of you yes
we're gonna watch that
but then after that we did four sets of
deficit deadlifts on a
timer and we were wiped after that so it
doesn't like that four sets of deadlifts
is going to have as much you know when
you talk about manipulating your
endocrine system
that's going to have as much impact as
25 sets of
lighter worms okay so you're an advocate
of heavy weight
low volume high intensity as heavy as
you can to the compound movements
because that gives you
95 percent of your results if you're
just trying to shock your body into
being
different yeah and also a caloric
surplus because that's a the you know
now i gotta eat yeah feed
you gotta feed and and you know
they have a child we gotta feed you got
that now i'm not a big eater
that's the problem i'm going to stay i'm
i'm going to stay a coat hanger
well that's also something i think you
could figure like people come to me
i know it works on the opposite end too
like for when people are trying to lose
weight
like but i don't want to eat chicken
well you don't have to you can eat the
foods you like in the right proportions
and i would say like is there anything
you like to eat like steak or
like something where i go i don't
believe in going
you have to eat this if you like
something can we crank that up
and get you in a position maybe maybe
shakes yeah right
shakes is a very easy way to be like oh
like people would be like i can't get
the 200 grams of protein today i'm like
you can't [ __ ] make a shake before
you go to bed the problem with all of
this is i'm then i'm
a 54 year old guy trying to put on ten
pounds right that's the real thing he's
like
okay but it's possible right mark
absolutely nothing
go ahead mark answer it okay
i gotta run some gear the other thing is
even that question is in the context of
like
i've heard that this guy did that for
this role it's
all [ __ ] [ __ ] oh dude it's all
[ __ ] yeah but they say i ain't
chicken broccoli
rice and i didn't know you didn't you
were juicing trench
so that's okay trembling is the the most
powerful
injectable anabolic steroid not free
like like you know what they are
not for anybody not for humans
so hey before he goes on should mark
start his own [ __ ] podcast i told him
i'd produce this guy he's
yes we already have another one don't
give out the name don't give out any
name
yeah but we have a name concept he
crushes it because there's no one else
in the
[Laughter]
cool you're getting shape man you're on
the road and stuff uh your friend that
looks like a street fighter 2 character
who is that
[Laughter]
just call it tits for days i just want
to finish that thought because anybody
listening who thinks like
to me it's criminal because these people
are trying to tell you something chris
hemsworth's like
oh it was his body double had some
article in muscle and fitness and he's
like
yeah i got down to five percent body fat
while gaining 20 pounds of
that's impossible even on steroids you
didn't gain 20 pounds of muscle
while dropping to five percent body fat
the picture you're showing isn't view at
five percent body fat it's
nine percent body fat and then the
funneling into the workout app where
you're doing like
bodyweight lunges and flipping like
that's not how you built the muscle
either so
everything about it is a lie and the
hollywood thing with whatever celebrity
you can think of who's done a
transformation recently
for a role whether it's zac efron or
camille non-johnny
they can't say it out loud no they're
not wait they're not allowed to say it
out loud no cause i was wondering i was
like why don't people
just say it because think how many kids
like yeah
but it's also like mr olympia on the
show and it was like tr we're trying to
teeter on
he's like you know i take muscle text
like you said yeah yeah it's the most
it was this yeah phil heath yeah we were
like remember we had them on years ago
it's like you want to be like what are
you running anybody selling
supplements you can't talk about it
anybody who's got a sponsored clothing
line
can't talk about it yeah independent
youtuber or something
there's certain pockets of people who
can be open and honest about what they
do but for the most part there's 18
different disincentives
yeah but is it because a lot of the but
is it because a lot of this stuff is
illegal or something
or what like it's it's crowded it's like
this weird dark i don't know
because it's like this weird dark cloud
testosterone i'm sure i'm sure you get
this mark like the
only reason you're big in shape because
you're on steroids yeah it's like do
take the exact same stuff i take right
let me know how it works out for to me
yeah actually what's interesting is you
can look at that yeah like it's like
dude first of all
the bodybuilders you see like how do you
think phil heath looked before he took
steroids
like he took steroids you know he
because his muscle insertion
you wouldn't get into professional
bodybuilding unless you people were like
holy
unless your base was pretty [ __ ]
right you know right but if you look at
for example there's various
powerlifting federations and cat you're
probably familiar with this right like
the tested versus non-tested
yeah the difference between tested and
non-tested
um federations isn't that much you think
like
the guys on steroids are squatting two
thousand pounds no it's like
15 percent more sometimes not even
because
like am i built to have a thousand
pounds on my back and squat it will snap
me in half yeah
certain freak individuals can do it or
just do that
like you know and at that level there's
just it's not as much as you'd think
because ultimately
like the tendon strength and the
the density of your bones is the
limiting factor whether i can bench
press 700 pounds
what would you what would you weigh i
mean you're a big guy would you weigh
if you didn't lift weights i mean uh
probably
160. no you still be in the 200s right
yeah
i eat a lot yeah i'm i'm large and i i
always had a big
appetite yeah so that was like that's
the main thing when you talk about i
don't eat a lot it's like that that's
never been the issue for me so that's
part of specific about your diet when
i'm cutting yeah but now i kind of just
go like
if i'm if if i eat the protein goal
every day then everything else kind of
falls in place because you're so
full you know what i mean or like i mean
i could eat more but then also i just
have like
certain things in my house or i'm like
i'm having the choice of eating this or
that
but it's confined to relatively healthy
foods right but you do a lot of cardio
too to like
i also do hill runs every day yeah yeah
yeah the kids got
legs yeah your podcast you should do
them in those
70s short shorts right you're one of
those boy ones i gave you yeah
your dick popped up about the front oh
it tops it it pops out
yeah he has a dick on him too why not
what's that kenny
and then let's see
his acting skills hold on then i oh oh
[ __ ] that's so funny
look at this i like your i love your i
love how
straight your back is [ __ ] pretty
good
today junior can you hear it in the
video i go to today junior it took
forever
wow that's no problem well i i that's
what i really wanna
i don't wanna [ __ ] myself up you'll go
up ten pounds a week you know
great form dude i'm just terrified to
[ __ ] myself up when it comes to that
stuff great form you're a smart guy
so i listen to everything he said with
[ __ ] you
if you say look 50 cent steals and other
man
that's like the catch i like the one
where you play the chick
i'm happy with the resonance of his
voice there we go the timber
yeah there's a there's a base to it he's
uh him on the road so fun
of course this 50 oh this is my favorite
skit turn this upgrade
is like serena does she
she's so hot by the way she's smoking
she's greatness
yeah i'm a big fan of your acting too
like
like the subtlety and everything you
bring because that's
something that i think people take for
granted like stand-up comedians
you know that's pretty rare right yeah i
think so i mean
yeah i think that because that's a
different thing it's beating into you
when you're in class
which which one is she um let's watch
jazzy watch jazzy
smoke show too that's her and she's that
talented and she's funny yeah and she's
fine
christ yeah and that's amazing she's a
unicorn she does this
if you go i'll go to toya turn up if you
can't this is her alternate
like she she doesn't stand up as this
like ratchet like
miami girl funny man that was so good
instagram
yeah how funny it is yeah so if there's
any video of her
watch like this is such a good she's
like she's like a ratchet girl
yeah she's great man
[Music]
[ __ ] talking about
target
and so just a side note on that because
people have accused her they're like
you're degrading black women with your
characterization now she's like no this
is a girl in my neighborhood that i'm
doing like
that was the neighborhood cardi b does
stuff like that she's [ __ ] hilarious
so it's yeah because it's not a she's
like i just grew up like i know toya
toys inside me from the older women that
i was around when i was younger so just
yeah for anybody who's thinking that's
like
her going ha ha black people are
ridiculous i don't think that's
hilarious
yeah that's called vomiting
she's gotten that critique from white
wokers
probably yeah that's where she's gotten
it from yeah from white people in
colleges expensive colleges
yeah yeah [ __ ] off like that's funny
yeah so
needless to say we can't get him to a
bigger size no
all right well no no hey he's not coming
what i'm saying is the approach that i
would take is opposite of people like
like the for example there's this this
um protocol called dc
training it stands for dog crap training
that's like this guy just chose some
stupid nickname and it's you know
forever dog crap training but it's like
for years i would go in and do one rest
pause set of
heavy exercises i'd go into like bicep
curls i would do a set to failure of 10
take 15 breaths do like to failure
another
broken set like of six and then three
and then you're done with biceps
like so this idea of like you have to go
in and do like
10 20 sets of a given exercise
if you go in and focus on lifting the
heaviest weights that you can and then
beating yourself
the next time and make that as frequent
as possible like that's to me your best
shot at
forcing your body to respond what i'm
saying is that you could put weight on
me
if i started running gear oh yeah and
then the second
component to that yes because what the
main thing that you're talking about
that's going to prevent you from
you know injury like you know
it's easier when you're younger when
you're 19 because you have testosterone
ranging through your body right if i if
you started with
like for sure if you're taking like you
know
something like anadrol or a certain
certain dose of [ __ ] you wouldn't even
have to lift and you're gonna gain
weight you know what i mean
just one thing well just because of like
so something like
and like a lot of power lifters take
anadrol this draws
like glycogen water increases your red
blood cells
tremendously like you know [ __ ]
everything is like
mineral retention everything about it
kind of
artificially adds weight to your body
kind of like when people go like oh
creatine makes you stronger but
you know it's like creatine is the
starting point and you know
that same effect of like drawing water
and other things into your muscle
it's not permanent skeletal muscle
muscle tissue but if you wanted
to make you stronger though oh no if you
take an anadrol right now your bench
would go up like 30 pounds by the time
you hit the gym
right wait to you know you're going to
take it at 54.
but would i recommend that no i don't
take anything if you were looking to do
something safely you would start with
testosterone
growth hormone and maybe insulin right
to help you absorb the food that you eat
and those are all
bioidentical hormones that you could
take for a longer period
of time
what video is this jen sent it to
video uh me rapping oh come on well mark
it looks like we're shooting a rap video
on the gym
someone asked us if we're shooting a rap
video look at this
[Music]
he knows every lurk every round
[Laughter]
do you know how smart this [ __ ] guy
is i can tell like not just in the
the muscle area i can tell in the muscle
brandon was talking about the muscle
brandon was talking about i'm all set on
friends
brandon's boyfriend yeah i mean the way
i introduced them like i snuck
pretty much right yeah actually
chappelle told me he's like oh yeah
brendan wants to meet you and work out
with you i'm like that's so cool
and then he didn't say any of that yeah
yeah we were friends me and chappelle
were going to the zoo culture and then
he just showed up with mark
and i hate when somebody brings a random
guy yeah but then
you know he's great yeah i've been
lifting it i just
i just moved you didn't [ __ ] it's
like bringing something on a blind date
it's like
oh my friend stephanie's here that's
crazy she probably like
chapelle knows everybody she'll just
bring some red like you brought his
little gay friend
you know he's like lifting a heart i got
a little gay friend he's little you know
he changed the weight off for him every
time
we're bringing random dudes into the gym
we did have to every time yeah we didn't
have to because like three is the limit
you know it's hard to work out with
four people four is tough and if you're
not doing different same weights it's
like
okay have we worked out four people oh
just i was just my homie
your little gay friend and then hey why
do you keep calling a little kid
little gay friend and then uh homeboy
homeboy with the hair like my son boston
todd todd yeah todd came in oh todd yeah
oh got it
are you still within the range of doing
our weight so that makes a little yeah
yeah he actually yeah
does our weight a little bit not really
was i giving them too much credit i was
why why are some of these strong men
from iceland
is that just a joke yeah okay that's
well okay guys
it's 300 000 people and the top
crossfitters and stronger are from
iceland well you know what i think about
this focus on it yeah
they're all just they're full hearted
yeah they're trying to work really hard
everything about like what you because
you you would probably think about this
they don't look like the whole fault
and like um the physics of like joint
size right for speed where it's like if
you think about the mechanics of like
how fast you can make something go with
the lever like you'd want to have like
large muscle bellies and thin
joints like yes you know i don't have a
sprinter's ankles you know
yeah right so but when you look at like
half thor these people from iceland
they're both tall and they have like
sturdier joints and just the way that
they're set up
they look like they don't win gold
though what's that they don't want to
kill
they don't look up hey i'm saying strong
man competitions and i would just
include like all the strong the
strongest strong man
spring to colorado right now but but the
strongest
man was thor for four years for three
years and before that that was matt
they've had a lot of
are you talking about magnus he's not
from he's not from he's from iceland no
i don't think so
magnus isn't from iceland he was look
look that up chin
also bring up the strongman like they're
strong but i wouldn't say they're the
strongest he's from a nordic country
i believe he's from iceland there you go
yeah he's from iceland he's a beast
but i would say in the aggregate right
yes there are there's
the one guy when the fighting you know
that jack dude yeah
um um he won forever he's i think he's
from uh poland that we're saying he was
a bodybuilder polish
yeah i mean he was a [ __ ] monster
stronger now
yes he went into mma yes
he's from poland yeah dude and he's 313
pounds
look at the body type and you go now he
looks great as a bodybuilder
yes he does but his look how thick his
elbow is so strong right
just like the distance between you know
or his weight look at his own
leaks i mean the veins is nice so he
wasn't ufc no
no set up to lift heads he wouldn't pass
the drug test
again a guy like that before he was even
lifting was
you know right he's soaked guys he was
so
insane look at that [ __ ] that's just
that's a cartoon character but but who
who on all the roads but uh
who dominates in the olympics it's it
it's america and china right
it's a little different though yeah it's
still there i mean china does amazing in
the lower weights
yeah um uh there's a guy um named
lasha i'm gonna [ __ ] up his name but he
turkey
georgia i think yeah so the eastern bloc
countries china's dominates all the
lowers but even like north korea because
they
like they're putting their barber on
your hands as soon as you can crap yeah
and the form is so important and then
also that's really interesting do about
the like
chin go to what countries has the best
olympics yeah they have scientists
though they have
so russia's numbers so so russia's
number one
china's number two bulgaria united
states germany uh
austria then poland the russian coaches
go to china they go to bulgaria
the the russian it's like the wrestling
yeah like that the great the great
greco-gut players are russian their
coaches are russian
it's the same thing with the power
lifting that's what they focus on insane
to the
weights that these guys can do crazy
over like i mean
like when i'm struggling to lift
deadlift 500 pounds and
they're approaching maybe even lasha
might have hit it recently a
pounds
and then they they literally squat it up
but yeah and that
snatches in one motion 500 pounds when
you see the speed of how they get under
the bar
so they they're they're dead lifting up
and when they when they get up they're
getting under so deep
it's so fast yeah watch how fast they
are
that's funny
yeah the way that he'll throw around
like if he was to clean and jerk 500
pounds it would look like a warm-up so
you know
yeah there's no 5.85 or more you know
what's cool is when they get done
they make so much money oh they do oh my
god dude
that's amazing the world is they're
always looking up like that the world is
the
oyster well the fastest way oh i was
like
watch what's happening you do nothing
watch how fast you do that 458 pounds
oh my god like what that gun do baby
oh my god that guts no punk either but
they need that weight wait so like they
don't have like sponsors or anything
like that
they might i mean they maybe they make
money their government subsidizes
it's kind of like cheerleading yeah when
you get done you know what i'm thinking
russia you're oh
america we really don't give a [ __ ] but
in russia unless you're michael phelps
yeah and
then are you aware of the like the
worldwide doping scandal as far as like
like wada and uh the doping worldwide
there have been these controversies
where countries
pay off eco you're talking about that
what it is
part of it but like china and russia
it's like especially china it's like
thanks for covering steroids you know
the the smaller countries yeah icarus is
super fascinating but that's like
one like state doing that within their
own state
i'm talking about like this becky stands
like look we want a [ __ ] gold medal
what's it gonna do for you to look the
other way
uh so there's so many athletes you
wouldn't think that guy's on steroids oh
no
because he doesn't look like it no i
knew he was and he has tested positive
yeah
and then he hasn't tested positive
recently but his totals are going up
from the time where he was on
it's like natural and then they
also had masking agents too right those
those those are never
going to get ahead of you no those
scientists are always one step ahead of
you
you're never even like masking everyone
every day
because that can take something like i
could take something and have it in the
system in four hours
yeah um and that's even if you were
testing me every day that's what bothers
me about like
getting rid of steroids and powerlifting
is boring like
you should be allowed to yeah i think i
think it's just part of every sport
in a sport those guys running gear and
again yeah
the difference though as we mentioned
before that's what i think most people
don't get
is it's not a hundred percent difference
it's a 10 to 15 percent difference
because i can take all the steroids in
the world and i'll never i'll never
snatch it
but it's like barry bonds like oh he's
only good because took steroids
well no he was he was good before yeah
got on him and that temp
10 for barry bonds is a world-class
difference
those guys did get huge though it was
really interesting to watch barry bonds
when he came into the league
and and same with sami sosa and uh
they were skinny they were skinny dude
like what go bring up sammy sosa
and and before and after remember when
they just said androstein and i went out
and got andrew
i did too yes i was like that's what
they're doing so hard on your liver
yeah so there you go like there was such
a difference there's a kid there though
yeah you talking about a 21 year old kid
then yeah yeah but also even the culture
of weightlifting because there's
probably a time when we get
bonds oh we shouldn't weightlift in look
at sammy though
[ __ ] yeah barry berry was 240 his helmet
size grew
that's what they said that's because
he's using a different helmet
that's why and his backspin increases
like this they get the kind of
three-pronged like you know
like the terry crews head right yeah
yeah yeah still a hell of a [ __ ]
athlete and nobody remember him
his daddy was a mlb [ __ ] legend but
nobody worked harder barry bonds and
mark maguire and all those guys
worked their ass also there's never been
maybe michael jordan there's never been
a bigger [ __ ] in professional sports
than barry bonds
notoriously known as an [ __ ] yeah
look at that
sheesh that's [ __ ] i mean he was like
you could just see i don't think my arm
has ever been that skinny in my life
right so you could say
ding classic you know i heard those
you said he went girl because she was
like asking for money
and he's like i know what you want you
want that ding ding it does sound small
super disappointing how do you not call
it a slugger yeah
yeah you're barry bonds that [ __ ] you
want that grand slam
oh yeah graham slan's a good smallest
member the smallest member of the
antelope family is a dick dick
he said it yeah he's skinny hell of a
player though yeah yeah they won't let
him in the hall of fame
nope he'll get in eventually do you guys
ever hit balls i can't hit a 70 mile an
hour fastball no god no
he has i did yeah in arizona i hit
exactly 70 miles now
and i kept hitting it and i i couldn't i
whiffed on everyone it was embarrassing
i was like i need to go to school i
played tennis though so my
my eye i think a tennis ball comes over
at 70. so for me it was
it was actually i i hit every time yeah
and i have the video
somewhere no you looked last time and we
didn't find it oh i haven't i thought
kevin tell me to look for it yeah you'll
find it okay did you
did you try to go up to 80. oh there's
no way i can't get my bat around time
and that's a slow pit like now think
about them throwing junk and you have
no [ __ ] clue what's going on here
baseball's impossible yeah dude i
couldn't get my bat around game of
losses
oh it's humiliating i tried throwing i
tried throwing from uh like
official like oh so far because like
give me a basketball give me ten tries i
can make a three pointer with nobody
guarding me so i'm like ah
yeah okay i understand how people can do
this under pressure it's nuts
but i i was like i'm not only missing
this i feel like i'm a half
second yeah now think of world series
bases loaded and you hit a walk-off home
run
what are the [ __ ] odds yeah and
that's a professional pistol he's
throwing
his best pitch at you yeah and you still
[ __ ] crank it off
nuts it's the hardest sport in the world
yes i tried pitching though i tried to
get up to
just seven you know those celebrity
games they they when the when the
they have like a celebrity do the first
pitch they always move
they it's moved up the mount's so far
dude oh because
people don't realize from the bounce
also like i know and i was pitching from
way back there
how far is that mill 65 miles an hour
through that's all that's all you throw
65 miles an hour
that's so pretty that's the new intern
woodsy's uh
place for syracuse orangeman you guys
went how far
in the in the tournament um well we lost
first round
sadly but you made it but she was on
espn hidden home runs and catching balls
yeah i was on sports center top ten um
for diving catch i mean everyone's
in college so i'll be honest not the
stereotypical softball player image i
have in my head
i get that a lot but to be fair
stereotypes exist for a reason a lot of
lesbians on the team or no
yeah two of my teammates are dating in a
very serious relationship like going to
get married the whole shebang and are
they are they like the butch lesbians
yeah one's the best one's the butch one
actually she turned her
so she was straight she was with a lot
of the football team first hell yeah
yeah and then uh decided she wasn't
about that football team anymore it
wasn't about those linemen and just
turned gay and then there you go and now
they're doing it fascinating now they
just love them now you're doing it
together yeah it'd be like it'd be like
do you pitch at all
i don't it's hard it's so hard it's so
hard the like little windmill motion
it's just
it's ridiculous because you know the
women's off while they do the wind-up
underhand
and a lot of the pros when they pitch
the professional guys because the
release is different it takes a while
for them to get used to
they were missing they were striking out
she struck out one of them struck out
pujos
and a couple of the other great because
what happens is a different distance
and and it's just it was just their
timing the release is different
everything but then they picked up wait
what's the average speed yeah
um well we faced clemson was the fastest
probably the
she's a freshman she got freshman of the
year and she pitched like 72-73
that's and it's like it moves up too
that's not like baseball where it's just
like a downward moving pitch like you
got up
side to side down like there's all types
of different you've played since you
were a kid
yeah since i was eight oh there you go
yeah so hard
game of failure yeah it really sucks
what are you so
what year are you at syracuse i'm gonna
this is my fifth year so i'm going into
my fifth year and then what do you
give like what does let's say you were
the best player in the team maybe you
are let's say you're the captain of the
syracuse
orange man which is weird because you're
orange women but whatever
let's say you were like the mvp of the
team what is their elite
i guess you could go to the olympics but
there's no there is a professional
league
really you guys make seven dollars yeah
you don't get you could play like
20 20 grand a year maybe like the best
players
20 30 grand like there's no money in it
whatsoever
everybody played in a professional men's
league and i believe he made softball
three dollars did your friend suck all
the debts he made a lot of money
we have a kickball league in l.a and
christian's part of it so he could sign
up for that if he wants to get sick of
jerking off dude those guys can hit a
ball i don't know can you imagine you're
going to watch your dad play ball
and then you see his buddy pitch it like
underhand you know you mentioned a
walk-off home run
if you do that in kickball it's like a
skip-off home run yeah how do you guys
do it
um it was kind of like the little little
hopscotch
uh thing to the first space yeah a
little bit
yes can you imagine for a kickball
league at your age
well i remember watching guys play
softball in central park and getting
in fights [ __ ] yeah getting in fights
over like a call and they're cleats and
stuff i hate guys
softball on the weekend you [ __ ] zero
and they had cleats
oh yeah and i'll tell you what else i
was asked because they were a shorter
man
to play in a touch football league on
randall's island
which is in new york city didn't want to
attack each other all the guys were all
xd1 guys and like big dudes like you
guys and i'm
i they were calling me brian piccolo for
brian's song which you guys don't get
the reference but anyway
uh james khan played brian piccolo in
brian's song he dies of leukemia it's a
very sad
but it's about a football player i
called you brian piccolo based on true
story uh yeah i uh i [ __ ] um
i played with these guys and there were
fights there were these giant
like just italian and irish guys and
they were just
there it is there i am yes oh that's
sonny from godfather and my son boston
that's also the real
gayle sayers i think yes it is yes it is
now i grew up playing handball in venice
beach
and another guy shot the other guy over
handball there you go see somebody
what's your handball we play for keeps
though yeah uh well
it's not even gonna happen but there's
handball but this guy got shot over
paddleball
so it's uh you take the air out of a
tennis ball they have like kind of think
of like um
uh uh what do you got ping pong kind of
a bigger ping-pong
tennis racket okay yeah and then my it's
fun it is some guy shot the other guy
because he lost
some dudes will get because become
complete [ __ ] they're playing a game
some guys you see a personality come out
you hang out with them known in five
years then
you play a game of touch nuts and
they're they're fighting dudes
wait what's happening what what's
handball it's like where you
a is of the ethnic guys mexicans
over there in venice beach and it has
the the like round
yeah it's like uh yeah just a wall with
like
that's not yeah
now you go to venice you better watch
p's and q's and be pretty [ __ ] good
yeah well now it's paddle tennis out
there and there guys and if you want to
if you want to clear the
the the arenas just go ice and then they
[ __ ] you
and then me and my friends play wait so
what about what's the object of this
game
like so you're throwing a handball you
got to hit the ball no now there's
handball there's butt ball you play butt
ball
bruh no that's not even a gay thing you
know butt ball it's like you so you hit
it you hit it
if it drops and then you're the one that
[ __ ] it up you got to run and touch
the wall before someone can grab the log
throw it in yeah
and then you got to sit against the wall
and then there's the one with butt ball
where you play
the game then you [ __ ] after yeah yeah
yeah and that and that's also
what his friend that's also what i
thought that's also what his older
friend who played softball as a grown
man did is
i don't know dudes played softball they
don't yeah they don't hey dude this
weird guy did no no they play no they
don't i don't know male softball that's
pretty competitive i'm going to be
honest with you
i mean [ __ ] yeah but just play regularly
hey
fast pitch softball how fast the dudes
pitch
90 miles an hour yeah i know but throw
it over hand or um
no dude they pitch crazy fast nah i know
and then they suck each other out after
they don't drink
three sons no watch this 77
77 all right can we see a dude pitch
because it's non-existent he said no one
like no dude i mean
if you look up mike white he's the coach
for texas uh
he is from new zealand and it's really
big there there's they play
fast pitch softball in new zealand
really yeah new zealand like big ass
dudes will just like throw it under hand
now i'm not even trying to be an [ __ ]
is it because they can play regular
baseball or how does that work out
that's a good that's a good point it's
new i don't know it's big in new zealand
for some reason men's
but it's kind of like cricket too right
like cricket's big out there or is that
just india
the australian place yeah that's
probably why because they've pitched
earlier
england they all pitched underhand is it
a regular bit
let's try to do my accent now this is
from 1984.
from 84. 84. so you're right no one a
lot of white guys out there yeah that's
84.
yeah they're all older is there any
famous black softball player mcmens well
not famous but there's not there's no
famous white guys
yeah there's no fantasy yeah there's no
idea anything yeah i use the word famous
loosely
now there's a nolan ryan christian who
played overhand
yeah i know him i'm saying softball
no
famous black socks there's a little
feller called nolan ryan
oh sorry of all time i think randy
johnson well now the guys beat it
now science been random has the fastest
bird execution involved yes that was
nuts insane thing about randy johnson
he's what is he six
eight six nine he's i think he's 16. how
big is randy johnson
think about him throwing a [ __ ] ball
at your face
he's 16. and he's built like a goddamn
t-rex
and that's what it helps right be like i
always think about this was like limbs
and
generating speed the length of the arm
right just to get that lever on look at
him dude
he brought arizona championship that's
right yeah
yankees right yeah oh they're comparing
the range on
practically six minutes these guys are
so tall those pictures most
of those features aren't that tall or
whatever no they are not these days they
won't be
tall guys okay 70 is not uncommon a lot
of dominican guys yeah one of the bigger
guys now is like 270 throwing 100 miles
an hour
i don't know if it's common 270 for a
picture i mean you see a lot of guys who
are way bigger than you think yeah roger
paul was 260.
roger i don't think he was two he was
two six no
no no bring up bring up roger
clements was huge dude he wasn't 265.
at one point he was maybe when he got
out of shape and retired i think when he
was playing he was a monster his weight
yeah playing weight way bigger than
people think two thirty five
six four two thirty five now that's a
[ __ ] yeah and randy johnson 225.
pedro martinez was wrong [ __ ] cause
they were like like they'll do that
yeah you're 235. like what are they
weighing you every week like yeah
yeah they weigh you mark you get
football right yeah right i was listed
for four years at 2 35.
what do you want what are you what are
you what working out what are you
walking right now what do you
what number probably 240 yeah yeah
you've seen the most everyone's seen
your 250
it's possible hey you know
he'll always make people go higher
chapelle was like would you say i'm too
sick i'm like bubba you are not too sick
i said i was 250. yeah i got it you're
bigger than 275.
not not right now whenever i first start
working out we're both really fat
and he he was like i'm 250 of the
chappelle i love you
you're every bit of 280. what do you
mean he was two seven i don't know i
don't weigh myself
yeah i stopped when i started you're
about to you've got to be 275. no
no god no i start off i've lost weight i
started off at 272. oh you did yeah i'm
probably 250 something now
but since i did that dead lift i'm
probably what what
you've definitely get lost i've lost
black but i don't get
muscle that's why i tell you not to
weigh yourself because i think you've
gained muscle and lost fat during the
pandemic when i was just
running and doing pull-ups and dips like
every day you know
gyms were closed and i was eating 2500
calories a day then i'm down to like
when i'm 2 30
i'm ripped shredded but then if i don't
want like
i'm not watching my diet i just eat how
long have you had that long hair dude
um since like 2016 and it's just
starting to look okay
what was it before i can't imagine it
was short hair what was it before it's
nice
really yeah well now now you you now
it's kind of a thing tie it back maybe
when we
do but i look like hello mark harley
like what's funny is when you get on set
you know bro
follow him come on dog um okay when we
walk down the street when we're in
austin we'd walk by a restaurant a group
of girls went like this to him they went
uh
all the way down um i think you just
passed it
no no a little bit your
one of those guys either chicks dig them
or they hate them um
yeah there's no inventory yeah
that rancid t-shirt they come but i
think it's a little
[Laughter]
you look like you're selling me a ponzi
she's got a big head yeah big
top head so you're top heavy up there
there you go mark you have the lawn here
bring the cow stage north
of that cowboy picture sage is pretty
tall that cow is not
just short is he yeah i thought he's
like six feet oh damn
rock of love
i remember this show one of my faves
that's a good question you just [ __ ]
all the girls yeah every guy
i used to not brush it and then you get
dreadlocks right so every i always
i tell women it's like i empathize with
you now because everything there's so
many mannerisms like going like this
before you like like
putting your hair out of your face to
eat drink from a water fountain
having to actually wash your hair or it
gets maybe you don't get dreadlocks but
i would like not you know
no i brush my [ __ ] okay yeah but you get
a lot of hair just left over on your
shower it creates another dimension of
upkeep in your life
that you know i didn't think about ever
how often do you wash your hair probably
twice a week mark do you
slowly think you're turning to brett
michaels as you get older yeah look at
him
how dare you he looks better than brett
michaels brett mike is a lot older
i'm saying when he's done like that i
heard that that's
actually like more so recently that's
not his hair because he had a he
i think he got sick or i don't know if
he had a stroke someone
yeah something with his brain or
something happened to where like
basically
i've never believed that was his hair
that's a weird daddy he's i
hulk hogan too i work with i work with
brett michaels
were you on rock and love good guy good
guys dudes like it but he seems awesome
yeah now the rock of love look you know
the back story with rocky love he
literally [ __ ]
all the girls like brett dude yeah we're
trying to find love here yeah
he wasn't trying to find love no he's
[ __ ] all the time i know a girl who
was on there who said that there's that
goes on that's that's what happens yeah
yeah yeah you need it
to confirm that no we all know that
you've never seen it
it would literally be like i'm going to
bed and like four of them would go with
them yeah
who's i'm sorry is he looking for love
are you just writing it
called flavor a little flavor he's a
super sweet guy
yeah he seems dope i will say that he
was drinking at the time like we were
doing this this thing was in the morning
he was yeah he was having he was having
his drinks and he's not a rock star
i can't drink right so i i can't have
gin in the morning but he had no problem
and he was funny and he was just a rock
star yeah you can't drink because you
don't drink or you i just can't drink in
the morning i'm
[ __ ] i mean oh gin oh i'm like yeah
i'm drinking in the morning i was like
well there he goes i'm not doing
anything after yeah he had no problem he
was just bang bang
and i was like that's a rocker yeah
sunset strip was different back in the
day yeah yeah where all those dudes
would hang out
like you're in the viper room and all
that when you go like oh you're gonna be
like him and i'm like i would just like
i don't give a [ __ ] if i
lose my hair or like age ungracefully in
my face i'd like to stay in shape though
like i wouldn't like to be
55 and immobile or yeah something like
that
that's the thing about how i feel like i
that's why i'm so afraid to do anything
because
to be completely honest i have a [ __ ]
load of energy and my body doesn't get
tell about your dick
right and i can do that too no tell them
about your dick game yeah
hard like a diamond yeah hard like a
diamond no no i do well in that area
and i do still and i can still i can
still like
the doctor like if i if you wake up with
a heart on sometimes
like they say your testosterone is like
a certain yeah it's a scientific problem
for me right so i would imagine you
have great testosterone also when people
well i did have reading you know
talk about the size you're not show me
nuts so it's amazing hey tell him about
the size
of him he has a bag of
coins absolutely yeah absolute
batman but more importantly i have i
just have energy and no pain in my body
so you have 54.
yeah i wouldn't yeah if i were you
because you're as much as i'd love to
see on steroids you don't [ __ ] with it
that i always anytime somebody asked me
out i'm like have an exit strategy if
you're not committing to this for the
rest of your life that's the problem
have an exit strategy because i've
you know guys that come to me and get on
trt or something then stop after like
three weeks i'm like what the [ __ ] are
you doing
like you just [ __ ] your endocrine
system up where you have to like you
you're not taking the right [ __ ]
afterwards now you're going to be
depressed you're going to lose all the
muscle that you oh it does that to you
oh it's a [ __ ] because it shuts off if
you put in any amount of testosterone in
your body exogenously
your body's going to like oh oh you got
it okay yeah you're not stopped working
that's why how does one get off of it
you take
compounds like uh hcc
clomid novadex these things that will
prompt your body
to start making action but if you don't
do that the user doesn't necessarily fix
itself
oh [ __ ] and guys have really screwed
themselves off yeah and that's where you
were like like oh i took steroids all
netty
thyroid everything gets kind of thrown
off everything has a
consequence to it so it's just you're
managing these side effects there's a
science to it and if you get involved
you should probably
haphazardly and that's that would just
be my recommendation anybody's like
[ __ ] researcher [ __ ] you know
somebody messaged me
like hey ah still so i wanted to work
out more what steroids should i take i'm
like
you're not ready to do that yeah because
you haven't read the first
sentence anywhere and you're using me
like google do that you should write a
book called steroids for dummies
there's so much stupid [ __ ] out there
like especially when i was you know
i would go on bodybuilding.com forums
and then
it was just like trial by error this
guy's like oh i took 500 milligrams of
tests this is how i feel
start to see like i guess it's also for
guys a lot of times guys like me if i go
on
the only reason guy like me is going to
go on is he wants to look closer to that
problem is that's gene there's a genetic
you have to be a realistic one too
because the amount like and you could
even see guys like this guy eric
kanepski
kind of got famous for like um he put
his cycle online and he was like i take
three thousand milligrams of test energy
two thousand a test probably like
the amount you're going this is not just
like twice what somebody could take and
get results you're taking oh yeah so
this guy
holy [ __ ] he is he's like 24 years old
or something like that
he's only 24. and if you see his before
pics the dude was scared if you could do
erikanewski before and after so that's
not he detailed his cycle
like 20 units of growth hormone a day
300 milligrams
and he looks like [ __ ] on stage that he
will never win a bodybuilding
competition if you look at that picture
he'll win my bodybuilding right
now he looks like a buff dude for like
youtube videos i'm saying not to knock
his
his like uh you know what he did to get
there
but he doesn't have that's only genetics
i'm talking 10 to 20 times the amount
that somebody had genetics could take
and get great results from right
all that stuff scares me i just want to
work out so that's the route you want to
take if you want to be a wwe guy and
you're
skinny or like now he's like a youtuber
and i think he's a good dude i'm just
like
people thought he was like exaggerating
what he took it's like no because
if you don't have the genetics you just
have to keep cranking it and there's
diminishing returns too
you think 20 units of hgh is going to be
better like is twice as good at 10 no
it's about this much better oh yeah
tattooed on his face so that's so is it
better to take steroids younger then
yeah no no here's one element of it nice
try christian
we see you dog think about it like this
if anybody's thinking about that going
have you even come close to maximizing
your genetic potential
which is this logarithmic curve of like
yeah in your first
five years you're probably going to get
most of it and depends on how
long you would want to like eek out you
know another pound of muscle every year
after
certain points get the newbie gains do
as much as you can naturally
learn how to [ __ ] train and if you're
approaching it like
i'm lazy and i don't like lifting but i
want to look good i'm going to take
steroids
wrong answer because it ain't going to
fix anything and you're just going to
[ __ ] yourself up worse
right so to me the the people who are
the best candidates for it it's like you
already lift you already know how to
train you already have a healthy
lifestyle
you are 25 or older or whatever your
you know 30s or 40s and want to start
trt because you've noticed your own
sex drive decline or you're depressed or
something else but you know but you have
to be in a position where you know how
to train
you this guy i know this guy i know
helps the nhl and
yeah he's he's really knowledgeable and
he also is a
scientist and he's also a guy who
actually knows
all the details he's got because the
guys he works with are athletes it can't
get caught and need results right
right and he said that a lot of times
with dudes who have
like low testosterone first thing to
look at is their sleep
how much are they sleeping and also then
he checks their magnesium zinc and
there are certain things where you'd go
and they're off your testosterone yes
yes so you can he brings that back up
yeah that's why oysters
they say because oysters you can eat one
oyster according to don d'agostino who's
uh
at the college of florida and you will
get all your zinc magnesium and all
certain minerals
for the week with one so one oyster
shellfish are so [ __ ] good for you
they're one of those
remember zma i used to say oh yeah yeah
yeah crazy dreams
yeah right always good sleep what's that
yeah it was the zinc
it
yeah it's such an interesting world to
me yeah but the sleep things if you do
something dude get on something i'm not
getting on
all this stuff that i was a little
creepy before i was asleep no i don't
want it impossible to maximize
it you just can't do it you got to sleep
you're eight hours man yeah
and that says yeah sleep and food it's
like you want to start anabolics
yeah start with the anabolic food and
sleep that you yeah
i'm telling you dude i watched it and i
went oh it's just a little too heavy
it's just [ __ ] heavy daddy got six i
did for the gram
use the belt i just use the belt no
that's for [ __ ]
the belt is good do your belts help them
yes
create can't go flat like like
intra-abdominal pressure because really
what you're doing is pushing against the
belt
which then stiffens your spine yeah
which i never got because but you can
i practice this by bracing you and you
push out against your stomach and the
ball solve a maneuver
i wish we had the video mark's face i
wish we
yeah it looks like he's being shocked
you always started like this who should
i send it to you
i got to see that i said well mark it
looks like you're in this place this
episode should be called flying to mars
it looks like you're flying tomorrow
it's
those power lifters their noses they'll
they'll they'll be lifting and you just
see them start bleeding oh that was
almost like dude i almost i was like
girls will start pissing themselves
yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] my pants in your
core yeah
[Music]
face though flying to mars flying to
mars
yeah look at that that's good for mark
trying
very happy with your back i'm always
learning very happy with it again
wearing a thick boy shirt added 300
pounds
wait how much was that again that's 4.95
five times a lot of weight that's my
first time doing that so you're dead
lifting 500 pounds
almost almost three i don't want to say
almost very close
that's five pounds look at that look at
that summer squash for a face
you you gotta
ugly lifting system like but if you're
not doing something with your face are
you trying that hard like
yeah you look like a model while i'm
[ __ ] bench pressing
that's just me judgmental i'm a dick get
in there
look at that he's flying your nose your
nose is pointing straight to mars
your nose turns right up it looks like
it looks like the g-force from the
rocket that's just that's right your
nose is you look like you're flying
through
look at that that nose how'd your nose
get that hurt you know that rep
was hard in the middle of it i was like
i don't know if i can get this you're
just holding your breath
pretty much he's breathing out yeah i'm
bracing but part like you have to
but the pressure would be there anyway
yeah this is going to be this yeah it's
[ __ ] heavy that's a great shot 409
that's my tattoo guys
you're getting that is that on your back
yeah
that is just well i'm chilling at my 425
i'm good i'm good
yeah yeah i'm not doing it i like your
500 you like my form
see you appreciate it man [ __ ] it always
let us have it let us have it man let us
have it
yeah let us have it sorry you're trying
to break our bonds
yeah let us have it intercepted all
right chin what do you got for us
uh first one's chappelle's actually oh
yeah yep
guys come to hello we also have a uh a
new
segment that's ready today if you want
to try that it's called tales of the
tape we have uh viewers
send in uh who they think they could be
in a fight versus like if
uh they sent in one versus uh they sent
him one where it's you versus all of us
so it gets who they think would win in a
fight they like send in like
themselves or other people yeah that's
great
maybe you're a veteran of the cbd game
and you have your favorites or maybe
you've wanted to try it but you don't
trust the brands you don't know where to
get it well
pipe down i got some for you i'm talking
about direct temp it's the one-stop shop
for all things cbd it's like amazon of
cbd
it's one simple website with all the top
brands in the world
the best brands of cbd all live in this
one
freaking shop we send orders out all
right the same day
order shipped quickly from direct temps
climate-controlled warehouse
most packages are delivered three to
five days from your order so you get it
fast
right to your doorstep direct temp
members get free shipping on every order
i do this i have a subscription so every
freaking time i'm running out
they answer the cbd bat signal and it
gets dropped off at my door because i
have a subscription
and if you have any problems they have a
24 7 customer service team
satisfaction 100 you get 10 off the
entire site
charlotte's web whatever the cbd product
you're using i bet you we offer it
go to directhemp.com promo code is thick
t
h i c c c is the promo code
thick for 10 off get your cbd right get
it from
freakingdirecthemp.com promo code thick
this episode of fighter in the kids with
the wonderful mark harley
is brought to you by on it supplements
what do you need is
is your brain a little foggy it's not
clicking working right
maybe you're a stand-up comedian maybe
your podcaster maybe do
too many shows well i take alpha brain
every time i do a show
alpha brain and also you think i did 600
pound deadlifts by myself
nope i had on it supplements flowing
through my veins the only reason i was
able to hit it
all right and you'll see as we get into
in this episode we have video of it if
you don't have video never happen i have
video suck it
so whatever you need creatine glutamine
uh virutech we have freaking
protein powder all sorts of protein
powders if you're vegan we got you
covered plant-based protein powder
protein bars whey protein we have coffee
dark roast
we got elk bars warrior bars fat butter
if your keto we got you covered
we have fitness gear battle ropes
kettlebells if you don't want to go to a
gym you're stressed out about you don't
want to wear a mask in the gym whatever
state you're in who knows the rules
cool do it at home we have on-demand
workouts we have streaming fitness
we have onyx kettlebells we have the
zombie bells we have club maces we have
it all battle ropes sandbags
there's no reason your ass should be too
thick go to onit.com
fighter for 10 off the entire freaking
website
that's on it.com fighter for 10 off
let's do it any particular order
you're not you're right one more one so
this is chappelle
versus mark yeah uh god
that'd be horrible i mean you guys are
both heavyweights and you're under 265.
so
i have a cheerleading background he has
a wrestling background yeah mark mark
was
state marina del rey 2002 what was it
what was it i think it was just i think
it was the county champion of marine
county
yeah you can't say you say like in
california my brother was a state
qualifier though and he was legit better
than me
well but you understand armed drags you
can duck on you double that i do have
yeah and so she pulls that face out of
water here me versus
if you don't know wrestling and you have
three weeks of wrestling practice
yeah yeah he's gonna be on his back
chabelle's gonna lose i gotta give him
um yeah i'm gonna
lose this [ __ ] fight that was an easy
one then yeah now
but wait i did do a question mark kick
the other day that he said it was pretty
good
did she i'll tell you the story of when
he was like how old were you when you
walked in and told everyone you were
karate black
oh yeah i was like i'm a boxer like and
and chappelle
walked in like he had like he was the
sixth grader in the dojo
yeah and made up like he was like i've
never done this before but i was like
actually blocking his
i was like like this he was like and
then i hit him with a [ __ ] punch like
yeah everyone believed it
bruh for sure i thought everybody was
going to be like you ran away because
you realized you know
you were
it's because i love karate films and
then i just [ __ ] i was like yeah i
know that [ __ ] it worked out
and it worked out cause they were like
cause like they were like you could do
backflips do all this [ __ ] how you learn
backflips like
yeah i would have you do if i had you
had to fight him when i was in your
corner yeah i'd say look at me
yeah i want you to run out i would want
you in one corner do a
sort of a half pike yeah just throw your
curl your body into them
spinning spinning we'll see what happens
we'll see what happens and if
if you anyone if you get me on the
ground i give up
yeah i give up i'm not trying to fight
on the ground i'm tired i'm going to
stop
knowledge would go a long way with you
what else you got just another that
one's easy
um this is chill though this is uh one
of our viewers
uh well she has a nose piercing so she's
probably pretty tough 410
14. olivia nogg vs uh esther
pavitzky
esther's background though like how'd
she grow up i wish we had background on
because i don't [ __ ]
have them like send in backgrounds now
obviously this is like a rougher
version that olivia not maybe it's 410
though oh she's uh
yesterday's only five she's young too
i'm gonna go with esther surprise the
dark darkness center being a stand-up
comedian yeah
somebody i'll go with that he just makes
you happy [ __ ] darkness
darkness all right um this is more
for if you guys have been to king of
sting
these two are gonna fight and my boy
george harris now he's lost 160 pounds
and he's at three so that's not
wrestled in high school he has a
darkness about him oh but he's 135
he has a little something he's also 46.
yeah i got him
stevie weavey's 46 yeah yeah i got
george harry really he looks great i
know
george trains and listen and he had the
tummy surgery he's down 160 pounds
and he's training so we saw him hitting
the bag though the other day he can
throw
his throat are you gonna
then go from there yeah do you know
david lucas does catch wrestling like
you showed me videos of it
he was like you could he's like you
could throw hands i'm like no but i can
rest he's like so can i'm like
no you don't he's like oh yeah and he'd
show me videos of him him doing catch
wrestling yeah now he
now he was a d tackle he was trying to
get alabama so he
yeah he actually looked pretty good like
you know are you are you allowed to
talk about the george uh the um logan
paul
yeah where you are i fly out tomorrow
i'm gonna make i'm gonna i'm
i would like to present to you what i
think could happen and i want to hear
what you have to do okay go
i i think i i think logan who is
athletic
was a very good wrestler in high school
uh has been
boxing in earnest for about three years
okay
and is 40 pounds heavier at least and
way taller
yes i think don't have a chance i think
logan
has a chance i'm gonna say this i think
logan
may very well just take what what floyd
gives him and
bang on his body hit him anywhere he
wants and floyd
might find himself up against the ropes
which he likes to be in
and it'll be a different game there
because he could get
caught or could get his if the fight
goes five rounds and he's getting his
arms beat on
no no hold on no hold on now now you
ever see him fight madonna
yes i have and do you see how the okay
yeah but keep going
much smaller and doesn't hit his heart
though doesn't oh he doesn't have as
hard as logan paul the world champion
madonna
from argentina world champion keep going
okay now this is great
and this is why people can buy this
fight and because people are [ __ ]
stupid hold on hold on because i've had
i've had people
instagram influencers and youtube
influencers come up to me at zoo culture
and go
man what's going to happen this fight
you serious yeah man logan's so much
bigger
yeah oh this is going to sell well you
guys actually think he's kim wins what
i'm trying to do yeah hold on
now i like things the more views the
better now if now there's a chance that
he won't put a if floyd doesn't want to
put a glove on him
he won't put a glove on him that would
be that would be what
normally happens the floyd's entertainer
finds it entertaining gonna entertain
you here's what i'm saying
so floyd do we do we think logan paul
who's never won a boxing match yeah
he's one of one yeah yeah and five other
youtubers yeah throat
body shots could be a problem for him
well now
he's coming here now now so you know how
your body starts are going to fall
are you suggesting well are you
suggesting that that that mayweather
knows how to put his glove where your
liver lives is that what you're saying
and now do you think he's going to him
to the liver and then go to the head and
knock him out in the fourth or fifth
well what i was thinking was that
was that because i like the madonna
approach which logan i'm going to watch
floyd taylor
he's never struggled some people thought
madonna won logan
protect your ribs protect your liver
here we are yep that's easy to deal
against
that's right berlin then just start
banging on his [ __ ] arms
banging on and just taking shots taking
the shots
and then and then and then just after
around five floyd's like my arms don't
work anymore
here's where it gets interesting so it's
it's eight rounds
[Laughter]
ten rounds it's eight rounds eight three
minute rounds with a minute break there
is there's no judges decisions and
they're also in 12 ounce gloves okay
that
has small gloves there's not 16 oz
they're 12 ounce gloves well
well think about it floyd's used in
eight ounces
so they're bigger gloves for floyd okay
okay which is news to me i found this
out today yeah
yeah and i'm not worried about that for
floyd either it's a little disheartening
yeah there you go no judges no official
winner red
knock downs legal ko up to ref
discretion
no head gear obviously 12 ounce gloves
eight three minute rounds
yeah the question is ken here's my
question for you now it's a win for
logan if you can just
last all year that's right he lasts all
eight rounds it's a huge win for him yes
now
here's my but to the last eight rounds
get your hand on my face the last eight
rounds
the last eight rounds okay he's gotta
keep there we go
he's demonstrating on this part of his
jaw and body boy's not bad at that body
and then he's got to worry about it
here yep yeah if i'm logan i just i just
barely i just
i just beer hug him for eight rounds
right it's not just the liver it's the
other side i just i don't box at all on
the outside and when we get close i just
hold them till the ref breaks this up
and then you just you rush your bulldog
in yes
i cover my face take the shots and then
bang bang bang and start banging off i'm
having
high gear i don't know how the boxers do
i go high gear what i'm saying
elbows as his core armadillo it's his
corner and i come in like this
as this corner i'm saying come in here
saying just last eight rounds you're
going to get
[ __ ] up last night keep your chin down
here like come in
my bang keep your eyes open and then
just hit his body just hit his arms
he's going to be here just knock him out
there's going to be some booze
people aren't going to like this yeah
there's going to be somebody now i want
to say this when you hit a guy like
mayweather and if i if i'm here watch
this and i go down here what happens is
if i hit him in the elbow
he automatically without thinking about
it he goes like that bat-bap and he does
this so bap-bap and hits you so now your
chin goes
up and that keeps happening so now you
go i don't like doing that when i hit
him so every time i open up
every time i open up and i hit him here
he's going to he's going to go
back and catch me back and then does
this so now what are you doing
now you're trying to do this but he's
he's got this after what he just said do
you still believe
logan look at me i used to i worked i
would never work with brian ever again i
worked so hard at boxing
i i was sparred i need to stop believing
i spread so much that my my like my own
trainers were like
you know like he even said you're
getting dizzy like i loved it so much
that i really worked
at like sparring i would get in with
wayne mcculloch who would just move
around who's five
seven fought at 119 and then went up to
what 120
120 dude i'm telling you that he if
i would start hitting him like if i
started connecting with the jab he would
be here
or here i wouldn't see it and he would
turn my head around he wasn't even
hitting me hard
my head would go what i'd go all the way
up or he'd hit me in the body
and that was after how many years of you
doing what logan
yeah but i was working hard at it and
i've done taekwondo and i mean i'm not
yeah
i know but i mean the point is that i
was doing well with other guys in the
gym
the gap between you and the weight
difference because i was going to ask
brendan like
if you're 260s you would see
heavyweights and you're going against a
200 pound best boxer in the world like
what's
that weight yeah yeah versus a 200 pound
world champion it's different because
logan paul has
no background in boxing yeah yeah no
background so it doesn't he could be 300
pounds the weight yeah the weight
doesn't
matter yeah like everyone keeps focusing
on how big he is it does not
way not a factor a guy from uh if it was
wrestling would be a factor
a male stripper who had some pro fights
came in and and knocked the guy out and
wayne told the guy
not to do that anymore and he did it
again and wayne got in
and wayne was again he's five seven he's
135 and this guy was 220
and all jacked and he's up he's a
stripper yeah in vegas
and wayne hit him in the liver and
apparently i wasn't there the guy
sounded like a goat
like nightmare and that was the end of
that he couldn't right
the better fight to talk about this
one's going to be fun but the better
fight talked about which is a real fight
to me is woodley versus jake paul
that's that's a fight yeah that's a
fight that's a [ __ ] yeah that's a
fight i told you guys when jake came
over to show time he's gonna get real
fights that's a
real term that's a real that's good for
him and anybody listen people going like
what what i'm like
you're telling me you don't want to see
that you don't want to see jake paul
versus town woodley because
because i really do now so so with tyron
woodley again
tyron's been training he's been fighting
since 2011 2010
okay yep and a ridiculous absolutely
chip a lot of knockouts too a lot of
knockouts
wild card box and train so he is wild
card boxing i was going to ask you about
how much
boxing is in a ton of time he has great
boxing
he's going to have seven knockouts yeah
20 27 wins
seven whereby knockout right seven
matches paul for taking this
who couldn't like this is a real fight
now here's the thing now woodley hasn't
won
a round in mma in 20 rounds
20 rounds yeah so to me i don't know how
much woodley wants it
here and i know jake paul is foaming at
the dick
but for this fight to be taken serious
as a boxer that's that's why simon
should be a factor
but i think tyrone woodley is going to
have that fight in him now after that
whole you think it comes back after all
this time so you think
you think he's going to have a fighter's
heart against jake paul the youtuber
but didn't have against usman didn't
have it against [ __ ]
covington all these guys you think comes
back they're also
during this they're also really high
like high
level fighters and everything uh jake
isn't
so if a former ufc champion
goes up against jake paul he i think he
will have the heart in
everything in it because especially
because like ben aspen
yeah different different different more
more of a world champ than woodley
but tyrone literally has more and i feel
like tyrone literally has
more
[Applause]
and here's the thing it's not an easy
fight for jake man yeah i don't
i i was baffled that he's the favorite
he's a slight favorite
jake paul is the slight favorite i
haven't seen tyron woodley box i've seen
him mm-hmm what are his boxes
in [ __ ] box yeah yeah william box and
he gets in there and bangs with johnson
yeah chael simon was making an example
of like he's like you know how wonder
boy if you let him
um control the pace
the reason these tyrant fights were so
boring between those two is because the
threat of the takedown
so jail was like yeah i disagree
i i think i think i don't think it was
because he was letting them control the
narrative
i think it was woodley just doesn't want
to do it anymore he has too many other
options
this is a huge payday yeah it's a great
and he
i think he will get up for the fight my
thing is like how far
out is he from wanting to compete in
yeah you know it could go either way
it's also really embarrassing to lose a
guy like jake paul it's really
embarrassing
exactly that's why i think it will
another like
tyrone woodley losing to kamar uzman i
mean yeah like it's embarrassing to lose
a fight no matter what but
to losing to kamar oozeman a lot less
embarrassing than losing to jake
paul colby covington versus jake paul
like as far as embarrassment for tyler
will be
what he knows too to lose to colby
because i want to lose to colby
yeah right yeah to me it's just how
about how bad does woodley
do it i do a food truck with him and
jake uh friday oh nice
with who with colby with jake paul and
woodley wow the food truck would be
different in miami hours different hours
yeah
yeah this would be awesome it's a great
fight though yeah i i'm excited about it
that fight happens now it's not august
28th like they're saying though i'll
tell you that much
but there you go i think canelo is
fighting the same weekend
now what canelo do against but
but here's the other thing with jake
like we want to hate on jake paul it's
like what him and logan are doing is
nothing new
and hamilah lee fought lyle zado in my
high state and a professional wrestler
jack dempsey fought like they've they've
all done these entertainment fights
so this everyone's throw shade on the
paul brothers and also
but it's been going on but also think
jake has three you know
how infant he is in his career he has
three fights
yeah three [ __ ] fights dude it's not
even that because not even against
like bob it's still three fights but but
but but you can do a good
evening the first guy i fought was a
[ __ ] yeah
like i said so for jake for him to in
his fourth
ever fight to fight a guy of woodley's
caliber
she's got to say i respect him i don't
know how you couldn't how do you know
how you couldn't if you know
i mean he and he's and then after this
now if he does
if he starches woodley dude showtime
might be like oh here's chelsea
and here's mike tyson show time then go
well here's a real boxer jake yeah and
then you can get a real guy who eats
sleeps and
trains boxing yeah and it's off to the
races it's a real career
very difficult and that's what that's
what outcome actually i'd rather
think about the two narratives like
three years three years three years [ __ ]
you
[ __ ] president absolutely yeah also
remember this a lot of the boxers you
see on showtime
get there whether they're mexican
whether they're you know whatever
they've been boxing a lot of times
at least since they were 15. a lot of
times they're in those youth things
from like eight years old so they've
been throwing a right hand
since they were eight nine ten years old
that that's the big difference that's
why
and so they've learned they've learned
that mid distance head movement
it's it's like such a language but jake
should be fighting those be fighting
those
guys
yeah no he should fight those guys when
he has 12 15 fights
i think tyron is the appropriate matchup
right now i think yes i think it's great
but i think it's
such a step up it's such a big step up
you can't make an equivalent step up
after that no but here's what's crazy
is he i still can see him knocking
woodley out yeah that's how talented
jake paul is
yeah the kicking [ __ ] box man even
though he's only been doing it for three
years
but he can [ __ ] unbox though yes
where
do you mean in his training i've seen
all the stuff oh you have wait so you
think he could knock woodley out yes
sure with his power he's got power yeah
woodley's got a chin though
no that he hit him didn't he go didn't
he go oh well no
he's a wrestler but he went the distance
with oozman who else he's very tough but
i'm saying
when you just this is my thing about
jake is he
as talented as you know some of these
other boxers no
what the scary thing is if you're
fighting a guy like jake
when i watch jake sparr and i watch his
training this was
his timing is what's scary when you see
a guy with timing like him like
even if he's fighting cans and training
the timing is what should worry you yeah
that means a guy can [ __ ] box yeah
man he might be just
look he's he's obviously got to give him
you yeah gotta give him credit and he
trains his ass off man
you gotta respect it because these kids
can make money playing [ __ ] chess
and sell millions of pay-per-views they
decided to go the hardest route in life
and fight for a living they're
disciplined dudes man i mean their
success is not a [ __ ] accident look
at this
see even if these are cans his timing
and distance
and his footwork and his head movement
he's very explosive yeah but again we
don't know the
the extent to the background of the
people that he's fighting christian
that's my point
i don't care his timing and everything
is on point
whether these guys are just handsome he
just took a shot it's not him
[ __ ] that right there
see the timing on the overhand right
yeah it's impressive
in is pretty impressive now can he do
that against a young cuban kid
his same age who's been boxing since he
was four probably not but he shouldn't
be
i don't everyone wants to do that oh i
want to see him fight canelo are you out
of your [ __ ] mind
all right i'll never be ready
he has three fights dude three fights
yeah he's an
open micro of boxing that's right but
he's a [ __ ]
you'll see you open mike you're like oh
that kid [ __ ] got balls can do it man
he's got balls but there's certain guys
you look at it yeah he can do it yeah i
respect that he's getting in the ring
with him like i respect that
i don't think that's guys i don't think
we've ever seen a guy like that who's an
entertainer youtuber
take it this seriously and actually put
his ass on the line well when he signed
with showtimes go [ __ ] kid wants a real
[ __ ]
i'm telling you dude i work with them
they're not gonna entertain the [ __ ]
show
when you sign with show time they're
gonna his team might go oh we want him
to fight butterbean they're like no no
he's gonna fight this guy espinota
espinoza was
oscar de la hoya's [ __ ] lawyer he
built floyd mayweather's career
he fight they worked with canelo like
you're talking about his royalty of
boxing yeah he's not going to throw his
reputation out the window and have him
fight [ __ ]
mike tyson some [ __ ] show that's not
happening he wouldn't want to fight mike
tyson my tess would box his head off
right now box his face off
you sound like you seem like you begged
a different side oh mike tyson i think
would knock him out
so quickly we're assuming that mike
tyson's fights are real like when he
fought roy
jones jr he's not going to fight jake
paul because jake paul is not going to
take a fall
we don't want to go down this road right
now wait a minute
can you do me a favor and just bring up
mike tyson hitting right now he
oh no i don't care you're talking about
mitts i don't care i've been in the game
for sure
he's a great boxer though he's still one
of the best of all time yeah
because i'm saying they're never gonna
fight no but i'm saying you wouldn't
you you think that jake paul would i
think jake paul
that it makes no sense right no one
would ever do that
no i know roy's fighting other older
guys i mean uh mike types fighting other
older yeah
so you that fight with roy and and mike
was
they didn't hit to the head brian so
they had a gentleman's agreement correct
and holyfield's giving the same
gentleman's agreement jake's not going
to do a gentleman's agreement
yeah he's going to try to jake paul
looks like he's trying to kill the
people
yeah that's what he wants to do so
mike's thinking mike would never
note about his psychology a lot of
people have accused jake paul being a
sociopath over the years and like one of
the things
she knows they don't feel anxiety right
psychopaths so surpass
he doesn't look scared of anybody if
you're trying to intimidate him i don't
think when dc came up to him
he was like he's trying to like
intimidate me i'm like i don't think
it's not where you can get scared of
other people that's my first question
logan paul when i get in that locker i'm
like hey where's your head at right now
yeah because those guys are
so it's it's not even an ego thing
because they've been successful
everything they've ever
done but i think they're so on of
unaware of what
level they're at in boxing fighting
floyd mayweather yeah
him and his team act i don't know if
these coaches believe it but him and his
team
the paul brothers think he's actually
going to knock him out
yeah because they're they're they're
just in this and jake has more
validation for the world so it's a weird
world where it's like oh you guys have
been oh
yeah you have no ignorance is bliss like
you have no i don't think he's here
no clue what you're doing you might as
well do open heart surgery man
you guys have no clue what you're
signing up for going to find out if
floyd takes it seriously
yeah i feel like floyd's going to take
it seriously after that
floyd's entertainment you know the same
thing he did with uh conor mcgregor he's
going to entertain he's not going to go
in there and starch him in 30 seconds
he's going to let he's going to feel
logan out people like man logan's doing
really well and then he'll take over
fourth fifth sixth round and stop him
yeah yeah
but he's gonna feel him out he's gonna
entertain the fans he's entertainer this
is an entertaining fight for him yeah so
you know
you don't think he's training for this
fight either like he didn't train from
regret i think he's training looks like
oh you think he's i bet he's getting in
shape but he's not
he's not he's not like spawning i think
he's got to be careful with his hands
his hands are very brittle from what i
hear is that true
i mean i'm sure he has all the boxing
gears i'm sure his
hands have issues but i doubt he's
worried about that is he he's he's
gifted cardiovascularly
yeah phenomenal yeah and it's funny to
me when people go oh
he's just a counter puncher and he's a
backflip fighter oh my god
have you ever seen one when he was when
floyd was
young coming up he was he was a knockout
he's a pressure guy yeah
he can do both he just fought smart as
he got older yeah knocked you down
yeah when you see the like look at him
yeah it's like canelo
have a prayer and touch him yeah now if
they fought now canelo knocked his
[ __ ] head off
and that's why floyd's like i don't want
that much because he's 44. yeah
the guy who's 26 was that great he's a
greatness you know but he's also the
smartest in the game everyone should
take notes because remember he fight he
knew canelo's gonna be the next big
thing
he fought canelo and canelo wasn't ready
he fought canelo at a time in his life
where he would
of course he was going to beat him and
they fight now yeah but you and i talked
about like the fact that like
okay maybe manny pacquiao's shoulder was
[ __ ] up i don't know he made him miss
dude see that one's tough because many
literally
one arm okay and that's why oh there's a
hundred percent truth
okay okay like most commissions won't
let them allow them okay that fight
should have never happened
we all got robbed over a hundred dollars
and that's why there's a lawsuit against
them okay
because who would pay for that point man
he's taking this fight but he has one
arm he's like i don't want to see that
[ __ ]
yeah he's gonna miss he has one arm
his shoulder was that [ __ ] up super
[ __ ] up his coach didn't want to take
the fight
but man he didn't want to let the fans
down damn
damn he's got too many things going to
see
healthy manny and a healthy they've been
the best
that would have been nuts this is the
best all right what do you got
continue on so speaking of great fights
the one that everyone wants to see
that's a fight that's similar weight
classes we've talked about it before
it still needs to happen both two
[ __ ] 10 years ago
that he's always wanted to do it i was
going to do it but then i remember after
i got to know brian moore it just felt
weird
that's why i didn't want to do it it's
not [ __ ] we should get in the ring
we'll [ __ ] we'll get in there what's
your background
with athletics or training zero
background athletics yeah yeah
no i just might do i feel like you're
gonna get tired real quick but
there's only one way to find it there's
only one way to find out yeah
you guys have talked about it for sure
brian's years yeah yeah no brian talked
about it for six years
brian has more muscles did you ever
fight growing up yeah i fought a lot
going on okay yeah so that's all
in the sky using the game show them a
[ __ ] scar
you don't think jim was driving around
on [ __ ] rice rocket [ __ ] people
you've been in fights before and
experienced what it feels like today now
here's the problem now
chin's not young but he's 10 years
younger than brian but brian has
more experience yeah and he does but it
would still be good that's why it makes
it
interesting i think yeah but i don't
want to hurt brian the problem is
hitting you and
trying to get you in the face is very
that's the tough part i don't want to do
that i don't want to do that
well then we don't have a fight right
but who would win though you guys who
would win
amongst you guys brian yeah
sergeant that means we have to do it
then muscle death let me go with brian
i'll tell you what i've seen right
tell you what we should do for real we
should get in the ring and just in the
beginning around
i'm not watching you hit each other in
the body hard no no no
and we'll just try it i just want you to
feel that beat you're gonna sock him in
his
fat [ __ ] head
enough like to hurt you we have to do
something
all right if you guys do just the body
don't film it you don't want that no but
i just want him to understand that so
we'll go like two rounds that way so i
want to see what your cardio is
no no a lot of times you just might just
get really tired you know what he's
doing right he's feeling you out
changing i'm not hurt
no no wait no no you guys aren't going
to do a pre thing
you guys are fighting when it counts now
now throw come over here for a sec
oh no you're not getting
[Applause]
go
ready so we're actually fine right yep
you see that jab you please
you're turning over that exceeded
expectations boom a lot of people
can't throw a punch okay you've shown
too much can i see a hook nope
you don't no
i want to see what you got i think it'd
be great i think cardio is going to be a
problem for both of you
yeah i want to see you guys you roll
around a lot no he doesn't
i haven't fought in a long time god dude
i haven't sparred about it
are we also gonna forget that chin goes
to get acupuncture for his bad back oh
hey man
hey we're giving away yeah the whole
thing is bad does the acupuncture work
fine i'm still trying it they say i have
to do like three or four times i've done
it
three times so far you know it doesn't
work for now i don't i don't feel
different
hey hey i know three or four though so
i'm gonna give it four okay i'm gonna
give it four rounds
let's get an ice bath and stop it i need
like a deep tissue
you need to you need to jump in the ice
bath what exactly is
playing grab something not brian okay
like crazy
do you have like a bathtub you can get
you a bunch of icing i didn't even hear
what you said
he said do an ice bath i don't have a
bathtub and he said you don't you need a
trash you said somebody put your nuts on
brian i don't know what
no i just said what did you fill up a
trash can full of ice and use that as an
ice bath that's what we did
what i'm saying i have a tub and another
bathroom what i'm what i'm really trying
to tell you is quit
wasting your time on that acupuncture
table i i'm willing to try anything so
where is your about so i wanted to give
it a shot i just have like really tight
muscle knots in my back because there's
another counterintuitive thing people
like will go oh my back hurts so i can't
do deadlifts
if you work your backbone don't correct
do a dangerous
weight you know yeah but like i've just
found that if i have like a stiff back
or something getting blood into it by
working it directly with stuff like
deadlifts
counter-intuitively it strengthens it it
can get blood flow in the area
and do something potentially there now
don't do this
i cured my back i had i had such a bad
back for 20 years i cured my back
without exercise not stretching telling
you yeah yeah i actually completely
believe that
that's gonna help you out my glutes work
in my core because doctors will say
don't okay you want to stay away or a
physical therapist
yeah stay away from these things and in
my experience embracing
the things that you know working a
little bit
my whole [ __ ] life with my back my
whole life you got a bathtub it was all
strength stuff yeah i just i realized
oh one of those trash cans oh yeah
that's what we did in football
i got a bathtub i'll do that i'll do the
best they sell like the equivalent size
thing online for like fifteen hundred
bucks
oh my gosh you know
replacing with a trash can is 1500 you
know how all these [ __ ] are using
like those uh
cryofreeze and all that do just jump in
a fight
i know i wanted to try that too it's a
hassle it's stuff yeah
it helps yeah how long do you staying
like first i stay in there right
20 minutes you know ice yeah man oh my
god
you're hurrying your body goes down your
body goes down though
your body goes numb your body actually
goes numb like at first you're like holy
[ __ ] this is awful and then your body
goes cool and just goes numb and they
just stay in there
and then you feel instantly better put
your hand and put your hand in an ice
cream people always pull out because it
hurts too much
you keep it in there go through the
paint then it just goes numb and you can
keep it in there
oh my gosh i hope they i'm gonna and
this is gonna be your road to fighting
brian yeah
because that's what all the like that's
where i first saw ice baths dude we did
it during dog days like we do three ice
baths a day in our full gear i take the
shoulder pads off jump in there
ufc that's all we did yeah but what do
we know jim keep [ __ ] no no i'll do
it
i'm gonna try it i didn't talk about it
i'll try it too it's great it didn't
also alternate between hot and cold i've
heard like the science of it it's like
it's if you have a hot attraction yeah
yeah
you know because we go 20 minutes hot we
go 20 minutes cold then jump in the hot
tub for five back in the cold
boom boom boom boom if you don't have
the hot dog
just do the cold yeah okay movement for
you chin working out you sit i gotta
work out for sure that's 100 i have to
i just do push-ups and dumbbells no you
got to do [ __ ] for your blue
it's hard to overload your posterior
chain with just
body weights that's really the only
thing you can't overload you know you
can so heavy
so if you could get a kettlebell uh-huh
and do
kettlebell swings you know you can do a
tremendous amount with just that one
movement
you know he's got to do that right
though right yeah all right a lot of
kettlebells you gave me one dog
get mark to show you how otherwise you
can mark that yeah
yeah but also he wants to be doing bird
dogs and those things that lauren well
he's only 180 so i guess he's 20
pounds away i like i lost so much weight
it sucks i lost too many
20 pounds what else do we got oh well i
was gonna say our new studio is
big enough to put a freaking ring yeah a
ring
yeah shoot it live all right all right
we could do the fight companion studio
it's big enough
all right and this is the best one i
think
that's hilarious yeah um
i'm gonna say that we would all beat the
[ __ ] out of them
because what's your game plan yeah
what's the game
who's the first one's gonna come in and
get down i gotta go first round
christian says he wants to be the first
now christians come running at me i'm in
the corner of the room
so he's here no he's going to
run it brandon yeah brandon brendan's
going to grab me with one hand and
hum me across the room no i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna kick you in the face
with my jordan one unions on and i'm
gonna spark and kick in the face
yeah so here's what we have you're out
600 pounds
energy to the fight i'm betting on
brenda chappelle this is to suck listen
to me right
now here's the problem cats will be the
toughest one to hit and she's cute what
i'm saying i'ma smack the [ __ ]
oh yeah open hand don't worry cat's
vietnamese and we're going to figure it
out she's going to get back
up now that's got strong legs yep so
here's the kitty cat right there
i'm gonna film me and put it on the
fancy listen to me now why would you do
this you need to bet you're a big guy
i need you to run straight at brad hug
me and i need you to [ __ ] get in this
grill
get your head on his chest and just grab
him and
hold on to him and i want you to jump up
and wrap your legs around his waist
and just be a [ __ ] angle so if i were
to do that to you what would you do hold
on hold on
i'm going to be punching him as hard as
i can okay
boom boom boom is going to be like
china's going to grab chin is going to
grab get on his the back of him with all
his weight
and he's going to start choking him so
you're asking chin to jump or i got a
better one
chin you're going to cover his [ __ ]
nose now and he can't breathe
it's a street fight yeah so you're going
to be holding him here okay so you're
going to be doing this you're going to
be doing this get on get on
get those korean hands on him on his
breathing apparatus
punching the [ __ ] out i'm not going to
touch cat cat but what we're going to do
you grab you grabbed his nether reasons
and just yank he's [ __ ]
nothing to do with this christian yeah
you call mark mark comes in
i don't want martial in the picture no
mark's not in there
we'll photoshop you later and he [ __ ]
chokes brennan's
wife
but you would have to have my back
because i don't want to just run in at
this at this moment
let me tell you you don't you don't you
don't do anything one thing about me
i'm going knee to knee with you bro all
right then i trust it
yeah i'll run at him i can't go in there
i don't have the scaffolding i don't
have the padding i'm getting [ __ ] so
we need to use this big boulder right
here's the other problem
he's going to try to knock you out he's
going to try to shut you off it's going
to hurt so you're going to come in
and he you might you might hurt they're
full of [ __ ]
yeah so you have to understand something
dude you got to talk i need you to cover
up
crazy because he's coming and it's going
to come back
if i cover up like this he can't knock
me out huh yeah if you can't see him
he's gonna he's gonna he's gonna be it's
gonna be a nightmare i mean does anyone
ever come at you like this
nope he'll knock you out that way
actually
yeah if you do that he's gonna hit your
hands and you're gonna go out
he'll hit you that hard you can't do
that now when we get in the hands
we should do chin brian and you should
try and jump me
ooh yeah we should like an initiation we
should do that like wrestling
whatever you want hey you just better
have my back
no no punches we'll do uh yeah battling
submissions dude that'll be fine
it was like dude this would be fun hey
guys hey guys i got this hold off
yourself
expect something
explain something daddy's lives are get
[ __ ] up yeah daddy's going to be
behind you
and all you're going to hear is this and
i'm not kidding good night sweet prince
oh you think you're in my back i mean
that's embarrassing go and i'm gonna eat
a whole [ __ ] onion
raw so you can just smell it yeah
[Music]
it's a lot of body weight okay are we
starting standing
yep
here's the problem he's grooving here in
front he's going to snap your [ __ ]
head down so you got to understand
and as soon as i tap your ass whoever
gets tapped so do i have to go in first
still you guys realize brenda's got a
world-class dars yeah he's excuse me
because here's the thing if i go in
first i could probably tie him out
okay here's what you're going to do
listen to me okay i know what to do when
he snaps you down and he's
and he will snap you down he's going to
get you you got to throw your hand
over his shoulder and push his hips away
and i'll be there to help
throw my hand over his shoulder and push
his hips away it's a bad situation
now as soon as someone gets stabbed out
you're out so let's do it yeah
so if i grab him like mm-hmm
you throw your hand over his [ __ ]
back and you push
you push on his belly button to beat the
doors push the hips
once it's in it's yeah that's not gonna
work no because if you i'm
guilty and you're doing that you're
doing guilty in here so
he's got if your head's here and he's
got you here do what he's talking about
dude so so he's saying i'm gonna grab
you officially
why you so great
[Applause]
take this hand and push his hips away
yeah try to pop that head out try to pop
that head out that big old head
don't do it do it yeah no no you got to
turn your head
try and fly um anywhere where your neck
isn't getting
pushed
if he doesn't want to do it hey man we
need your help if you want to try it
yeah don't don't hurt him because you
almost hurt me and i weigh a lot
no yeah bro you know what you don't try
to wrestle me in
phoenix remember yeah you hurt me then
sorry yeah hurtful he's he's he's
trained he's trained
it's he's got weird leverage and he's
got weird angles right now are you okay
yeah
yeah yeah no he could kill you very
quickly all right now so here
all right so now what are you going to
do you're going to be you're going to be
again you wrestle at all
no you have two brothers just christian
just feel this for a second before you
get crazy
feel what he's going to do so so so go
ahead go on corner so you're in there
okay now okay now christian now hold on
now christian here's what i want you to
do
get your hips okay get your knees up on
there get your knees up on there
and push away push away with that push
him there that's it
younger brother that made you want to
tap his life
the problem is a lot of guys don't know
if you've never rolled with a guy like
that what happens in their guys your
size can do it to you too but
the the that leverage where he where he
can crank a lot of guys can get their
head here and it'll work against regular
guys yeah with him
it doesn't matter what you're doing it
doesn't matter if my head's here and i'm
doing everything i've been taught
the pressure alone is going to break
your face that's why
i yeah steve mcgregor oh he just had his
face
your jaw is going into your uh like that
and you're you're done there's some
there's small guys you can do that like
chrome crazy could do that to me and
like well that's not true brandon
i know cronkite news i love that you say
that stuff yeah and i appreciate crohn's
a
genius and i really do appreciate you
say that the truth is
you're a [ __ ] silverback and every
most of the other guys you're going with
are simply they're they're monkeys it's
a different thing
so if you really start using your
strength unfortunately
there's nothing you can do a regular guy
could do how many
there's nothing how many brandon sized
guys would it take to overtake an actual
like in the same scenario were you
strategizing okay there's a silverback
gorilla
is it 20 guys the problem is
this is what you have to do it's got to
watch if you can't say it that way but
you have to say so brads are like
and they have to they know that their
child's life is at stake so they have to
fight to the death
you can't you have to have a very real
reason to charge the silverback okay
so you have four oh my they're using
their bare hands silverbacks are 600
pounds
six feet and also just pound for pounds
so much if they were our size too they'd
still be
yeah and you could take a look at this
look at this ankles take a look at their
look at their ankles there's no ankle
no it's just girth foot look at their
mouths
that that mouth is biting you so yeah oh
yeah and then
where are you gonna ankle lock them yeah
so what do you do what are you gonna do
and the chimpanzee is strong enough to
rip you apart
yes yes so now what are you gonna do
what how are you gonna hurt him i asked
he can't knock him out look at those
[ __ ]
to the right chin yeah no yeah that's so
cool i don't know there's a different
one this one's not as cool
would you have to get to it looks like a
guy in the car i think that makes him
more crazy because
even though he's blind he's still
fighting you in fact he's not feeling
that
he's an animal that's an animal and he's
jumping at you
have you seen how big their hands are
they're so big it's so weird
it's a different kind of strength it'd
probably take 20 men yeah and he's like
and i'm
i don't think they get tired either
they're [ __ ] vegetarians you know
yeah you're gonna have to you're gonna
[ __ ] look at that hand yeah
and if they rage when they're raging if
they're raging we're gonna have a big
yeah like if we take one of his little
babies and we're like we're like yo good
luck in this
you have to take away each of his limbs
and his mouth
that's a i get you to have four guys on
each limb
i mean who i don't know how are you
gonna stop yeah you can do it you get
four guys in each line i don't think
their strength isn't
cause he's just gonna there's just
there's just no way
no you could stretch him out you stretch
him out
yeah we stick a banana in his mouth we
stick a bunch of bananas in his mouth
yeah i don't know what you do you got to
have a lot of guys
you simply he's so thick yeah he's
so the terror the terror is in look at
that one that one looks beatable yeah no
go
go back you know that one has a chest
like brian that one look at that
look at that that won't be tough that
one we can be well we've already got
this
one do me a favor and go to hairless
chimpanzee i want to show you
their musculature when you're getting
knocked out is it a matter of like
what's the
is it the thickness of your skull the
strength of your neck like what's
preventing a
a gorilla i'm not gonna grill out yeah
well please take a look at a just a
chimpanzee go to that that one
uh that that's that's a full that's a
male chimpanzee that lost his hair to an
allergy
now take a look it never lifted a day in
his life i don't know if you know that
take a look at those left
those hands aren't made for sewing
they're made to rip your
[ __ ] visage how ashy anybody
talks about getting a
take a look at that one there yeah
that's it we're talking about the nuts
on that thing
yeah can we talk about this
and they'll rip they'll yeah your arms
off sir
yeah they'll no they'll take their your
arms off and they bite you they would
take that 600 pound deadlift with two
fingers and go like this
and that's it that's not a they're not
that look at that one down there look at
that that's one of my favorites which
one which one
the one with the balls hanging down
there that's it yeah that's a big male
the one with bro oh dude the one with
brian's face no now
the one with brian's face
that might be true but now do you have a
problem with his with his uh
with his delt development there look at
his [ __ ] legs
you know it's insane i mean mark look at
his look at his look at his body says
again
now that's a chance not a day like
that's 200 pounds that's 200 pounds
now at 400 pounds enough to that think
of a hairless gorilla correct i don't
know is there hair
i don't think so i don't think this is
going to shave one down maybe so i wish
they would
hairless silverback yeah now now that's
a add 400 pounds of that please
if you could right hairless green not
really not really that's the closest
thing
yeah well well i'm not mad at that
look at that oh you're not [ __ ] that
thing up nobody no you're not dude
that thing is shredding ten people are
not [ __ ] that thing up
it's so i think gorillas like have the
strength of 10 like
average uh males is that what they say i
i don't quote them it's not 100 percent
contractile strength of the tissue that
they have is just different like brian
was saying it's not
fine uh fine motor skills we have yeah
yeah but it's just like the boots like
you could say okay you have the same
amount of
of um just lean tissue that a human has
the the chimney
stronger than 20 adult humans jesus
gorilla can lift 4 000 pounds
a well-trained man can only lift 820 i
mean that's insane well no
now so four thousand pounds on a bench
press so now you're talking about
that's so stupid and that chimp who has
given treats
that female was pulling uh some crazy
amount of weight she was pulling with
what she was one hand rowing
and he was like so i'm impossible
so oh so yeah and by the way did i
mention that they have
feet they have hands for feet yeah and
their feet they got they're like
handsome
you're fighting four hands yeah like he
can choke out with his
foot that's right he's choking i'd
rather fight like you know because you
you're like
men have defeated like a mountain lion
who's attacking them you could kill a
mountain lion if you're really motivated
yeah
but you just can't do that with a monkey
or no if he you know
you give us sharp sticks sharp spears
even then
he's he's going down he will rip that
out of your hand no we throw him at him
yeah men brought down woolly mammoths
with organization
yeah and with sharp spears with steel i
would still rather fight a woolly
mammoth than a gorilla
probably yeah probably all right jane
give us um
should we do currently it's up to you
yeah i think we're good we covered my
phone you wanna just do
chappelle's channel listen because we
had a lot of talk
about uh nunchucks here oh and so
watch this guy get down all right you'll
love this song
this from uh bloodsport
fellow chuckles watching oh damn [ __ ]
cute yeah you got him you're gonna write
in the hat
yes yeah his name's
kush offerson that's a kid that's missed
a lot of school look at him
look at him i'm buying into the hype
right now this music's fantastic oh
loving this he's a ninja so yeah you're
gonna [ __ ] with that guy and his
nunchucks nick
this is so great oh [ __ ]
oh that's insane it was
i mean it's just kind of like whatever
yeah like street technique
oh is it do rag gun it's just two numb
trucks he's using chugs
he's using it he's got you yeah again
out he he can use him
he gonna [ __ ] somebody else do you think
he went to nunchuck's school first now
you know nunchuck school
i think what i think happened is he
missed school and then he spent
all his time doing that homie homie gets
down yeah
that could be your face who do you think
would win in a nunchuck off him or
michelangelo
that's a [ __ ] honest question that's
a good question is that the one that has
nunchucks michael yeah
yeah remember remember the line fellow
checker eh
oh yeah yeah there's a school in culver
city where they practice knife fighting
oh really with with electric knives bro
he's [ __ ] badass he's just so good
no he's [ __ ] sick yeah when i watched
the ninja turtles as a kid i fantasized
about like being like you know like
you're getting shots from some store and
you're like i'm gonna hey you you know
they're redoing uh
teenage mutant ninja turtles and seth
rogen's directing it
i would [ __ ] see that yeah look at
this yeah he's kind of turning into a
[ __ ] but that was yeah
is that a joke you saw his body you
wouldn't think he could do all this
stuff but he's got
you gotta give this a real awareness
yeah he's impressive
know what the [ __ ] i think is just
pathetic there he is
yeah i wouldn't fight that guy no he's
athletic he's super breathless
just because he's pudgy doesn't mean and
rate his skateboarding skills
he's good at skating he's really good
look at him go yeah
and he could be [ __ ] by its cover
that's all i have to say
you get [ __ ] so when you said no one
can [ __ ] somebody up in a nunchuck fight
this guy can what would nunchucks
actually use for cause i remember like
reading that size
like what raphael had was used to break
but they were built used for thrashing
wheat
for for for separating something like
that yeah
i was like was there anybody
warren villagers have been pending fire
so it's a noisy
yeah it's not gonna it's not really
great for home chugs began to be used in
english in early
1960's 1960's initially applied to style
of martial arts shortly after
particularly employed in style
yeah yeah i watched smart i watched the
little event of the dragon uh
yesterday and it just doesn't hold up
does it no
that's stuff dude [ __ ] was
illegitimately disappointing
uh and we got that and then albany funny
bone me and dub david off june 18th 19th
and then
helium comedy club come see me in philly
yeah there's another 25.
i won't have num chucks neither will
chappelle or david lucas but we will all
be in oklahoma city oklahoma next week
june 10th through the 12th tickets
almost sold out go right now to
fatkz.com for tickets that's june 10th
through the 12th that's next
thursday through saturday brickstown
comedy club oklahoma city
and they haven't added yet my brother
well soon pittsburgh in raleigh
north carolina is on oh it's on there
look at that
pittsburgh just went live july 2017
improv yep ooh it's work improv
uh pennsylvania july 22nd through 24th
he has the other one on their chin rally
north carolina
rally august 19th the 21st
rally yep there you go tickets at fa
tkz.com if you want to add 300 pounds to
your bench or deadlift go to
thickboy.com for thick boy t-shirts yup
no promises though and then this weekend
i'll be in appleton wisconsin
at skyline comedy club and then july
15th through the 17th 17th i'll be in uh
lutherville timonium maryland love it
man conspiracy social club moving to
rockfin
full-time in july and mark you'll be
i'll be posting funny memes to my
stories on instagram at hella mark
harley and
no he'll be in oklahoma with us yeah
you'll be in oklahoma with us yeah make
sure you watch logan paul floyd
mayweather this sunday your boy will be
there
there we go outfits all right kids we
love you but
we had fun late late